Tomorrow is your close
reading exercise number 3.
RAVEN DERAMUS: I love working
with teenagers, because I think
they just have so many
things in their brains
that they want to
say and get out.
And I love being able
to explore with them.
It's very, very exciting.
My name is Raven DeRamus.
I'm a senior here at
Princeton, and I'm
teaching 11th-grade American
literature and journalism
at Princeton High School.
I just want you
to get in the habit
of thinking and questioning,
thinking and questioning.
OK?
All right.
So this is my first question.
It's just really crazy
that they didn't necessarily
trust me in the beginning,
because they didn't
know me as well.
But now they look
for me every day,
and it's so great to see
them operating with me
as their guide, I guess.
KANOA MULLING: The Teacher
Prep program at Princeton
is a certificate
program that helps
you to be prepared to
teach at the high school
level or the middle school level
in the subject of your choice.
And so there are a few classes
that Teacher Prep offers
that, if you want
to get certified
as a teacher in the state of
New Jersey, you take those,
and then you embark on your
student teaching experience.
And by the end, if
everything goes well,
you are certified in the
state of New Jersey to teach.
BARBARA FORTUNATO: While I was at Princeton,
I did know about Teacher Prep,
and I thought about being
a teacher at that point,
but it wasn't something that
I wanted to do right away.
After thinking about
it for a long time,
I decided that I really
wanted to pursue teaching.
And I thought that teaching
was a very difficult job,
and I really wanted to
go back to Princeton
to get support in learning
how to be a good teacher.
And so I found
Teacher Prep, and they
were very welcoming
to alums who wanted
to pursue a career of teaching.
What should the
angular momentum
be after he flips the wheel
when we consider the system?
STUDENTS: Still l.
BARBARA FORTUNATO: Still l downward.
KANOA MULLING: I think my favorite
thing about teaching
is when I'm able to make that
connection of mutual trust
with a student.
And that can be
academic trust -- them
willing to show that they
need help on something, them
want your advice on something
academically — and
that they trust
you to give that good advice.
RAVEN DERAMUS: So this backs up
our claim that pearl
could represent salvation.
Now that
I'm doing student teaching,
I realize that it's
really, really for me.
It just really took some
experimenting and reflecting
for me to get here.
And I appreciate that about
the Teacher Prep program.
They really make you
think a lot about why
you're doing what you're
doing in the very beginning.
And so I really came to
terms with the kind of person
that I am, and the things
that I want out of life,
and people that I
want to interact with,
and what I imagine my days
being like on a daily basis.